good afternoon i'm carlos alone so the
acting Dean of the Graduate School of
Arts and Sciences and this is the second
of six events in the research Without
Borders series for the 2010-11 academic
year which is sponsored by the scholarly
communication program the Graduate
School of Arts and Sciences and the
School of the Arts professor Hall will
speak and then we will have time for
questions from the audience I would like
to announce that we are videotaping the
event so if you have a question for him
please use a microphone in the middle of
the room Gary Hall is professor of media
and Performing Arts in the School of Art
and Design at Coventry University in the
UK
he is the author of culture and bits and
digitized this book the politics of new
media or why we need open access
now he's founding co-editor of the open
access journal culture machine director
of the cultural studies open access
archives see search co-founder of the
open humanities press and co-editor of
OHP sculpture machine liquid Books
series he is currently developing a
series of political in traditional
interventions recently dubbed quote
deconstructions in the public sphere and
a quote which used digital media to
actualize or creatively perform critical
and cultural theory he's also involved
in the writing of two monographs media
gifts which has been designed as a
follow-up to digitize his book and the
free Libre University tour digital post
humanities I would like to leave you
with a teaser which is a quotation from
Professor Hall's
digitize this book which I encourage you
to read because it is a wonderful
warning about the the mystification of
open access and of digital technologies
as utopian and
an inherently democratic and contesta
Tory realm and the quotation reads as
follows open access cannot always be
position as being politically
progressive in every situation and
circumstance for the foreseeable future
open access may have the potential to be
democratic but as we have seen it is not
always on every word Democritus in every
conceivable situation open access also
has a potential to be neoliberal for
example so there's nothing intrinsically
or inherently democratic or even
political about open access and of
course the title of his presentation
today is as you know radical open access
in the humanities
you very much can you hear that
it's okay yep loud enough okay so happy
what products this week everyone I'm not
really sure if that's the right term is
it happy open access is it Marie open
access I'm going to go with happy open
access okay so I'd like to begin by
saying thank you to a few people to the
scholarly communication program and the
Center for digital research and
scholarship for inviting me the School
of the Arts and the Graduate School of
Arts and Sciences for co-sponsoring this
event and Catherine Pope of course for
organizing my visit and Carlos Alonzo is
very generous introduction as you know
what I'm going to be talking about today
is open access in the humanities and I'm
going to focus on the open access
publication of books in particular it's
they're generally considered still
considered it may be in the process of
changing the most important mode of
publication in the humanities I'm going
to be detailing some of the work that's
currently done in this area and some of
the issues involved and to do that I'll
partly concentrate on open humanities
press which is the open access publisher
I've helped to co-found I'm then going
to look at some of the forms that the
scholarly book length arguments can take
when it's will air released from the
majority of commercial marketing
concerns and be produced by open
distributed communities of researchers
okay but let's begin right at the
beginning with open access open access
is concerned with making peer-reviewed
scholarly research available online for
free to all those with internet access
and generally takes one of two main
forms publishing in online open access
peer-reviewed journals such as fiber
culture and culture machine and vectors
or in central subject or institutionally
based repositories such as archive in
physics and social science research
network those repositories authors make
their work this work may or may not have
already been published elsewhere they
make it available by self archiving
digital copies of it in recent years
however an increasing number of open
access book publishers have emerged -
including some of those you can see here
academic open book publishers repress
and so on oh it's fair to say that the
open access movement has progressed much
further toward the goal of making all
journal articles open access then it has
toward making all academics academic
books available in this fashion and
there are at least four reasons for this
the first is that open access has been
developed extensively in the STM's
science technology and medicine so the
open access movement has concentrated on
the most valued mode of publication in
northfield
the peer-reviewed journal article Raa by
the way stands for research access meant
exercise it's what we do in the UK every
5 or 6 years to assess people's research
and assign them funds so the second
reason what connects us hasn't
progressed so far in terms of publishing
books is the restrictions to making
research available open access
associated with copy publishes copyright
and licensing agreements can in most
cases be legally circumvented when it
comes to journal articles if all of the
options fail authors can simply self
archive a pre refereed preprint draft of
their article in central
object or institutionally based
repositories such as PubMed Central
though many publishers now allow office
to archive the refereed and accepted
final drafts of their articles so you
don't really have to resort to that the
problem is it's not quite so easy to
elude such restrictions when it comes to
the publication of academic books there
because the author is often paired
royalties in exchange for their text
copyright tends to be transferred by the
author to the publisher the text remains
the intellectual property of the author
but the exclusive right to put copies of
that text up for sale or give them away
for free then rests with the publisher
which may mean that the author is not
legally allowed to self archive even a
preprint version of their book
another reason the the open access
movement is focused on journal articles
is because of the expense involved in
publishing books open access this is one
of the main models of funding open
access in the sciences or the side fees
is not easily transferable either to the
humanities or to book publishing
the fact is authors in the humanities
are simply not used to paying to have
their work published and they associate
doing so with vanity publishing they're
also less likely to opt in the grants
from either funding bodies all their
institutions needed to cover the cost of
publishing off appears that the
humanities receive only a fraction of
the amount of government funding the SD
aims do only compounds the problem I'm
not going to get worse than the UK
government rumored to just RTP aunty's
very much at all is the fact that the
high rejection rates in the humanities
as compared to the STM's mean any grants
will have to be significantly larger and
all that's just to publish journal
articles publishing books or for peers
would be more expensive still fourthly
in contrast to the authors of
royalty-free journal articles book
authors were for a long time miss
definitely portrayed within much of the
open access movement as requiring
royalties or fees in exchange for their
writings and this has been unwilling to
give their research away for free by
making available open access however in
recent years things have begun to change
with regard to the publication of open
access books now want to highlight two
changes for you in particular
the first concerns the number of book
authors who are recognizing the
importance of making copies of their
work freely available online a small
number of authors are even refusing to
sign any contract the award copyright or
an exclusive license to a publisher and
our publishing only with those who bring
their book out on a non-exclusive basis
that allows them as authors to make it
available open access by publishing on
their own website or in an institutional
or subject repository other authors are
coming to an arrangement with their
publishers whereby copies of that book
are made freely available online with
only the printed version being made
available for sale
more or less at the usual price for an
academic book so Ted strippers here will
be an example of an ortho recently
published a book with Columbia
University Press in this fashion still
other authors are taking the decision to
publish with or with an open-access
publisher right from the start so lev
manovich is publishing his new book in
for aesthetics with Bloomsbury academic
while Giancarlo's raw is publishing the
cultural politics of the new american
studies with us at open humanities press
why they doing so what are the
advantages that are offered to book
authors by open access well it's true
that the mainstream print only academic
publishers and university presses are
often positioned as bringing a certain
amount of value added to the publishing
process they do so by virtue of their
ability to employ professionals to carry
out tasks such as proofreading copy
editing design publicity marketing and
distribution
nevertheless many academics are coming
to the conclusion that the kind of
value-added a print only press can
supply is insufficient to compensate for
the many disadvantages associated with
publishing a book in this fashion these
disadvantages include will the length of
time the generate extra print only book
published with a mainstream press to
appear this is often anything between
nine months and two years after
submission of the final manuscript the
high price switch press is attached to
their books and the effect this has on
the accessibility in dissemination of an
author's research non open access books
are available only at specific times and
places according to bookshop and library
opening times for example and then only
to those who can afford to pay for
access to them in the form of book cover
prices library subscriptions and so on
if you're not in an institution in North
America Europe or Australia
english-language titles can be expensive
and hard sometimes impossible to get
books published in open access
however instantly accessible for free
from any desk or laptop anywhere within
with internet access 24 hours a day
this means open access books are more
visible and easier to search for and
find which in turn means they're more
likely to be used and consulted while
evidence from the sciences suggests
publishing open access significantly
increases the amount of text is cited
but there's also the need for
conventional academic publishers and
even university presses to make
decisions about what to publish more on
the basis of the market and a given text
potential value as a commodity unless on
the basis of its qualities a piece of
academic scholarship so many are now
more interested in readers introductions
textbooks reference works than they are
research monographs the boom in the UK
at the moment for instance is now for
academic stroke trade books focusing on
particular films and TV programs right
so if you get a younger academic
starting out in the career and they
submit really an exciting research
monograph they'll tend to get a reply
that says that's really really exciting
but have you thought of doing a study of
The Simpsons or something like that
which is fine you can see interesting
things about the Simpsons but this last
factor is currently making hard for many
authors in the humanities to publish
books that are perceived as being
difficult
advanced specialized or obscure radical
experimental or often Gard it's also
making it hard for early career
academics to publish the kind of
research led monographs that are needed
to acquire that all-important first time
in the first full-time position since
they need to have one or two books to
get a foot on the career ladder this
means we're in effect letting publishers
make decisions on the future of the
humanities and who gets positions and
who doesn't on an economic basis
according to the needs of the market or
what they believe those needs to be
rather than according to scholarly
values
but academics are also publishing open
access for ethical and political reasons
many humanities disciplines like to
think of themselves as being politically
engaged yet the humanities have
something of a blind spot when it comes
to the politics of the academic
publishing industries would actually
make them possible especially those
industries have become increasingly
consolidated and profit intensive in
recent years that said however more and
more humanities scholars are coming to
recognize the importance of making
copies of their work freely available
online because they believe well that
our commitment to the value of research
carries with it a responsibility to
circulate it to all laws who are
interested in it including those in less
affluent parts of the world rather than
restricting access merely to those who
can afford it as we do now
that's the admin John will Itsuki mix in
his book the access principle but
they're also doing so because they
believe that doing so helps create a
healthy democracy but breaking down
barriers between academia and the rest
of society the source applying with the
public with the information they need to
actively contribute to political debate
open access is seen by some as
neighbouring the production of a global
information Commons and helping to
produce a renewed public sphere with the
kind associated associated with Jurgen
Habermas some have even argued such open
resources can help to reassert the
Academy's role as a leader leader and
Guardian of free and open inquiry and
convinced the public of the value of
universities as for the question of
royalties the reason I say it was
mistake to position book authors as
always requiring royalties in exchange
for their writings is because academic
titles and the humanities well they
don't
loyalty's at all in the UK at least
academic titles in the humanities often
only chief sales of between 200 and 600
poppies so very few authors of academic
books actually have much in the way of
royalties to lose like the royalty-free
authors of academic journal articles the
writing in the main for reputation
dissemination influence an impact and
only indirectly for financial benefit
this is another reason open access is
proving attractive to even the so-called
for-profit royalty fee authors of
academic books because like the authors
of royalty free journal articles they
too are realizing that they start again
from the interest in potential readers
and exposure giving their work away for
free can bring as this can lead to an
increase in the size of their audience
the level of their reputation influence
impact in a sting unless to greater
opportunities for career advancement
promotion peeresses funding
consultancies etc so one change this
occurred in recent years has to do with
a number of authors who are recognizing
the value of making their books freely
available online the second change I
want to highlight could sense a steadily
increasing number of publishers that
have been set up to make it possible for
book authors to publish open access so
early I said that one reason the open
access movement is primarily focused on
journal articles is because of the cost
of publishing books open access how is
it then that these presses can afford to
do so
well some open access presses are run by
scholars on a zero revenue zero expenses
basis any funding comes in directly by
their institutions paying their salaries
as academics these scholars are simply
using some of the time they're giving to
conduct research to create open access
publishing opportunities for others no
common mistake that people make when
they hear about this is to think okay so
there are now some open access presses
but they're run by academics then they
won't have the time the money and the
expertise to perform tasks such as
proofreading copy editing and marketing
not to a professional standard anyway so
such a scholar read scholar run open
access publishers aren't going to be up
to offer the same kind of quality as a
conventional press but even if some open
access book publishers did decide to
save on costs by reducing the amount
spent on jobs such as their copy editing
and I'm not saying that they do I'm
saying if it can still be argued that
this is a decision worth taking if it
enables scholarly books to be made
available open access I'd agree with
Peter Suber in this respect when
speaking of open access journals he says
that the best solution is to find enough
revenue to pay for copy editing however
we have to choose I'll definitely prefer
open access without copy editing to copy
editing without open access yet while
some open access publishers are run by
scholars on a service to the profession
basis not all open access book
publishers are operated entirely or even
primarily by academics many are
themselves professional commercial
presses
Bloomsbury academic an imprint of
Bloomsbury publishing group PLC
publishers of Harry Potter are an
example other open access publishers are
university presses so Australian
National University Ypres press for
instance which has produced more than
200 titles and six years still others
oppresses either established by or
working with libraries so she's
Athabascan University's ear you press
which is part of the laws whole campus
alberta digital library which lists
almost 50 titles in print and online for
free on their website many scholar LED
open access publishers such as repress
or even able to generate the money to
peer professionals to perform tasks such
as proofreading and copy editing by
operating on a freemium model readers
can access an open access version of a
text online for free but can then choose
to peer generally at cost price of
something reasonably close if they would
like the convenience or experience
offered by a print on demand edition
still for all that open access in the
humanities continues to be dogged by the
perception that online publication is
somehow less credible than print lacks
rigorous standards of quality control
and this leads to both open access
journals and book publishers been
regarded as less trustworthy and
desirable places to publish and it's to
professionally risky the career early
career scholars especially miss
precisely this perception of open access
that open humanities press the open
access publishers established with siggy
yacht current David or Tina and Paul
Ashton is being designed to counter
as thinking up can puts it which pzm is
to ensure that open access publishing in
certain areas of the humanities at least
meets the levels of professionalism our
peers expect from publications they
associate with academic quality so OHP
was launched in May 2008 by an
international group of scholars very
much a response to the perceived crisis
in scholarly publishing whereby academic
presses in the humanities have cut back
on the number of research their titles
they bring out in libraries are finding
it difficult to for the research that is
published both books and journals in the
first instance ought to be consisted of
a collective of already existing
high-quality open access journals in
philosophy cultural studies literary
criticism and political theory while all
these journals are of high quality
many had a problem generating a high
level of prestige because their online
journals rather than print and because
although at least two or all the ten
years old now most of relatively new and
you can get quality quite quickly but
prestige takes longer to build up so the
idea was to bring them together under a
single umbrella that of OHP erased their
profile and level of prestige in the
eyes of academics and administrators by
way of a meta refereeing process so to
this end I'll show you the previous
slide to this end which Pierce an
editorial board that include that
includes Alain Badiou Jonathan color
Stephen Greenblatt Gayatri Spivak and an
editorial oversight group consisting of
a rotating body of 13 scholars drawn
from the editorial board which it uses
to assess its titles the plan when we
first started was to spend the first few
years establishing a name and a
reputation for HP with its journals
before proceeding to tackle the more
difficult problem of publishing
book-length
material open access difficult for the
reason
I've given because of cost and because
in the humanities books published
electronically are traditionally not
held in particularly high esteem things
have developed much faster than we
anticipated however as soon as OHP
launched a lot of people asked us when
we were going to publish books so almost
by popular demand we launched a no HP
monograph project run in collaboration
with the University of Michigan
libraries scholarly publishing office
beautiful University of California
Irvine UC alyre library and the public
knowledge project headed by John
Wolinsky at Stanford University and the
idea was to move forward both open
access publishing in the humanities and
the open access publishing of humanities
monographs and we've launched our
monograph project with five high profile
book series as you can see the way it
works is all of Audis books are being
run through the university of michigan's
scholarly publishing office nest suite
of services they be made freely
available full-text open access online
as HTML and nearly all of them PDF -
we're also planning to offer print on
demand and eventually epub books
SBO is subsidizing the production and
distributing and distribution costs and
providing its services and kind in
keeping with its mission to provide an
array of sustainable publishing
solutions to the scholarly community
we're looking to use print sales to
cover production costs pay off the
royalties and to subsidize subsidize the
cost of other or HP titles so it's this
partnership with SPO is going to enable
us to afford to continue to produce open
access books over the long longer term
and to maintain high production
standards in the process yet for us it's
not just about making books available
open
access at the moment the majority of
texts have been produced by open access
publishers are still recognizable as
books in the conventional sense and for
the most part or HP is no exception
however we also want to go a little
further than this further even than some
of those who were already exploring the
new forms that book-length scholarly
communication can take in the era of
open access and online publishing for
example a number of authors have
experimented with making books open to
pay a commentary at various stages in
the writing process so mackenzie walk
did this with game of theory while
Kathleen Fitzpatrick has recently done
something similar with her book planned
obsolescence but in both cases Walken
Fitzpatrick remain the clearly
identifiable authors of these clearly
identifiable books as to them that these
books are to be attributed what's more
both of these texts were designed to
eventually appear as more or less
conventional hardcopy printed books a
version of Gama theory came out with
Harvard University Press and planned
obsolescence is forthcoming from New
York University Press in 2011 so these
projects are still what I call paper
centric HP we're going one step further
than this and experimenting with a
series of what we're calling liquid
books edited by myself and Claire
virtual like laws of walk and
Fitzpatrick these books provide readers
with the opportunity to comment on
respond to and debate with the texts the
author and other readers the difference
is were publishing the forum volumes in
this series not just under open access
conditions but free Libre content
conditions too so these books are liquid
not just in the sense the free for
anyone anywhere to read they're also
open on a readwrite basis the uses to
help compose edit annotate translate and
remix them
hello i'm cha virtual i'm gonna call and
this is our experiment in liquid to baby
one of their thinking's behind this
whole kind of project was that people
often don't get to see how books are put
together know the rationale behind
choosing say you know one clip of
Derrida on YouTube over another like why
has that one been included what's
important about that why is that there
so almost demystifying Rosa we didn't
want to have it fixed and kind of solid
want people to be able to negotiate with
it
the idea of things programs broadcasts I
don't really know what to call them is
this yeah maybe we can engage a little
bit through this process publishers have
put more and more emphasis on people
like us reduce texts that they are gonna
sell so if we take we research a subject
and we take a monograph on it the
chances are they're gonna say well this
is all very interesting but who's gonna
actually read this could you turn it
into an introductory textbook do you
consult the first-year students and
they'll be much more interested it's
very hard harder and harder for people
to publish that kind of research this
kind of research led to text
particularly for not already making a
name and even then even then it's harder
but the beauty of this isn't that you
can that the users can also add their
own link their own text so that real
frustration when you're reading a book
and you want the reader along with that
book that you get to the reader and it
doesn't have all the things that you
really wanted it in half
and so this is a chance we need to make
the ideal reader to accompany our
original book of unite for students for
yourself just to make a whole experience
out of it so if somebody for example
somebody saw our reader and thought well
that's kind of interesting but my course
is I can use some of that but I can't
use these are the texts and what I'd
actually like is a text by litter for
example then they can just do a version
of it obviously you can't do that with a
paper book you can't do it in terms of
scale and you can't do in terms of cost
and you can't do it in terms of popular
looking into whatever you want really do
we find that it's out there and it's
available online so we can include
annotations we can include just links to
an interesting website welcome to liquid
Theory TV my name is Carol and this is
Gary cool okay we're trying to fill up
all the way through yes no no these
things you need to tell so we're gonna
start by seeing a little bit about what
we're doing here exactly what are we
doing
the idea is for these liquid books to be
produced in an open collaborative
decentralized multi user generated
fashion not just without by their
initial authors and editors but by a
multiplicity of often anonymous
collaborators distributed around the
world indeed at the time of writing the
project has over 100 users from Brazil
South Africa Hong Kong the Lebanon
Europe the US Canada Australia and New
Zealand among other places what's more
that particular form authors have the
freedom to include all books in their
liquid books along with pages snippets
references annotations links to related
material even podcasts and YouTube clips
means many of these books can't be
published as printed volumes at all
they're more specific to the digital
medium than that all which is designed
to raise a number of challenging and
provocative questions can reproduce
critical and cultural theory in this
collaborative way what does it do for
ideas of the author publication content
creation quality control even of the
book itself I realize some of you may be
thinking that all this talk of books
authored and edited in a decentralized
fashion like this or nothing like a
large scale this Navin God fantasy on
our part yet there's already been a
dramatic decentralization of authorship
one set of figures claims that from the
Year 1400 onwards book authorship
increased by nearly tenfold in each
century today however authorship
including books and new media is growing
nearly tenfold each year they have some
statistics like by 2016 everyone's going
to be authors and things by the same
token a publication is mainstream as the
new
times has already experimented with
decentralized editing in the form of a
personalization platform called my times
it was designed to allow you to select
headlines from almost any section and
many external sources as well and
arrange them on the page in anywhere you
like and this experiment led the
software and audio-visual performance
artist Amy Alexander to speculate on the
possible long-term effects of such
decentralized editing on the importance
and value of famous publications such as
the New York Times now for exam such a
scenario would indeed lead to a dramatic
downsizing of the New York Times's
Authority and status to be featured in
The Times is still regarded by many as
Neyman of the importance she writes
but would that same level of importance
be perceived if a New York Times story
resembles a cross between an Associated
Press wire story and in our SS feed my
question in turn is could what Alexander
predicts for the authority of the New
York Times of implications for that of
academic stars such as a gamblin litter
Dziedzic and so on
and indeed for academic authors in
general is one of the possible long-term
effects of the rapid growth and
predicted authorship coupled to such
decentralized and distributed editing
going to be shift in power and authority
here - not just from the monograph - the
collection or reader but premier
academic author to the academic editor
or curator or compiler and with that
will the importance and value of the
famous academic publisher of non-quality
be similarly downsized to the point
where publishing with Harvard or
Columbia University Press or in journals
such as nature or Die critics becomes no
more silent importance than appearing in
the New York Times does in Alexander's
account or is there a potential
changing more profound than that it's
interesting that the shift in authority
for excellence and ER is only from
author to editor blogger to compiler and
for me this is simply to replace one
source of authority the author with
another in the form of the editor or
compiler which case didn't really bring
the authority of the author and the
question at all it merely transfers that
authority to different location far more
interesting is the potential liquid text
after it questions for these alternative
sources of power and authority too so we
can passively rely or neither the author
nor the editor the blogger nor the
compiler to write text with authority
and validity rather we have to take more
rigorous and responsible decisions
regarding texts their importance value
and quality not least because the actors
that perform these roles as either
authors or editors are often no longer
clearly identifiable or even or was
human in the year of Google News instead
both the author and the editor functions
are dissented and distributed across a
multiplicity of often anonymous actors
with often unknown qualifications and
credentials even more radically still
it's not just the identity and authority
of the author and editor the such
decentralized and distributed
distributed editing potentially brings
into question it's that of the work
itself
for instance one thing this project
could be said to be doing is D centering
the author editor functions making
everyone potential authors and editors
in this respect the liquid book series
can be positioned as addressing an issue
rid raised by net theorists yet loving
wire wiki's not utilized more to create
develop and change theory and
theoretical concepts instead of theory
for all its rethinking of concepts which
is writing the author the subject the
text a my third continuing to be
considered the terrain of the sole
author
who contemplates the world preferably
offline surrounded by a pile of pile of
books my fountain pen in a notebook too
bright an example in this book the soul
at work Frank will be for Berardi she
also for Italian composition astir ISM
the science of source of transformation
is much closer to the chemistry of gases
then to the mechanics of sociology there
are no compact forces unitary subjects
that promote unequivocal wills he writes
there's no subject opposing other
subjects but the transversal transversal
flaws of imagination technology desire
before proceeds to combine workers
theories with the skits analysis with
Deleuze and Guattari
developed a concept of the subject as a
violent imposition on a chaotic world
composed of a floor of molecules yet the
question to remain remains to what
extent is the schizoid understanding of
a subject being enacted by before
himself in his actual role and identity
as an author here just in his text in
this case is printed paper book Saul at
work very much remained that of an
individualized liberal humanist male in
its mode of creation composition
accreditation publication dissemination
at the same time in what is an author
Michele Foucault warns that any attempt
to avoid using the concept of the
individualized human author to close and
fix the meaning of a text risk leading
to a limit and a unity being opposed in
another way by the concept of the work
so we may have raised questions for
conventional notions of the author by
making our liquid books available and
open editing and free labor content
conditions but to what extent does the
bill
uses to rewrite remix reversion these
books render untenable any attempt to
impose a limit and unity on them as
works what are the political ethical and
social consequences of such liquidity
via DS that depend on the concept of the
work for their effectivity laws
concerning individualized attribution
citation copyright intellectual property
fair use academic success promotion and
so on we wanted to use a wiki for
raising such questions because the
networked distributed structure of
wiki's means anyone anywhere can
potentially join in publish and
participate this last point is
especially important with regard to the
center periphery model of the
geopolitics of knowledge speaking of
research without borders in this model
there are just a few nations at the
center of the global academic and
publishing networks who are exporting
and in effect universalizing their
knowledge and interestingly enough this
is the case leaving the most radical of
theoretical works works which in that
content explicitly tried to undermine
such center periphery models tick laws
of Michel Foucault who call writes and
publishes books of philosophy in Paris
they picked up by the US and UK
publishing networks translated into
English and his theories of power good
for mentality bio politics and care of
the self are then exported around the
world meanwhile there a host of missions
outside the center of the global
academic and publishing networks who
while they may be able to import
universalized knowledge don't have
enough opportunities to publish export
or even develop their own universal
knowledge to rival that of Foucault or
by jewelers
there are various reasons for this their
language may be a minority warned people
working in these countries often don't
have the kind of access to the American
quality research literature is taken for
granted by those close to the center of
the geopolitics of knowledge which need
to be referenced for research to be
accepted by international journals and
publishers and their peer reviewers nor
do they have the kind of local academic
or publishing networks that can help
them get read and cited this will
produce develop support and disseminate
their work in the first place that
mostly scholars may get to export
empirical data which provides local
detail that can be used to flesh out the
universal knowledge of those closer to
the center of the DOP geopolitical
knowledge networks now the wiki medium
of communication can be of assistance
when it comes to avoiding the
reproduction of this state of affairs it
seems to us not by enabling us to place
more emphasis on the so called periphery
say by privilege in contributions from
outside the center that says in 2004 90%
of the world's scientific research was
done by just 15 countries so we're not
trying to place more emphasis on the
so-called periphery there'd be real risk
without of maintaining that center
periphery self-other
model use of the wiki medium of
communication can be assistance because
it makes it possible producer
multiplicities academic and publishing
network one with a far more complex
fluid distributed the dissented
structure they could book series there
for us the capacity to be extremely
realistic we could even have multi
locational multi polar multi medium
multiple identity
books if we wanted which is something
I'm currently working on with my media
gifts project talk about that indeed
what's interesting about some of the
changes and developments in digital
publishing that I've described for you
to do it's not just that more books are
now available open access nor that with
the emergence of the like subscribed
blurb issue and loulou publishing a book
is something that nearly everyone can do
today in a matter of minutes not even
that as a result book publishing is
steadily becoming more like blogging or
vanity publication with the
certification provided as much by
authors reputation or readership or the
number of times a text is downloaded
cited referenced linked to blogged about
tweeted about bookmarked ranked or
indexed and this an effect recommended
by others in what amounts to a process
of collaborative evaluation as it is by
conventional peer review or the prestige
of the press it's published with the
really interesting thing about all this
is the way it encourages to think
differently about the book itself
there's something that's not fixed and
unified with definite limits and clear
material edges but rather liquid and
living constantly open to being
annotated edited updated and reimagined
with publication no longer being
conceived as an endpoint or fixed moment
in time but simply as inaud an ongoing
process or flaw so which saw the paps
will soon no longer call such things
books at all II or otherwise
on the other hand perhaps book is good a
name for such things as any to die to
argue books have always being like this
books have always been living in liquid
digital technologies simply helped to
make us more aware of the fact that's
all thank you very much
33% of the instructional force
nationally in the United States is not
tenure-track in other words 67% of the
instructional force in higher education
right now is not required to produce
research its contracted exclusively for
serving as a teaching class let's say
and it seems to me that that what you
may be trying to do is create more
outlets more diversified venues for a
kind of knowledge that the Academy
itself is beginning to face out in an in
a sense it may be that the kind of
knowledge that is produced by the
humanities has lost its legitimacy in
the in the commodification of everything
to the point that there is there is no
way in which to we articulate value for
the kind of knowledge that that the
humanities produces so that that in fact
what we may be doing by having by
implementing some of the recommendations
of the the digital humanities for
instance is to to produce more venues
for a kind of knowledge that is at some
level already hollowed out by the
dynamics of the of the university and I
know I'm not telling anything you don't
know but but I'm I'm wondering if the
concentration of the discourage
on the academic context when that
contact seems to have already made a bet
that that kind of knowledge is not going
to be part of its future is is
productive yeah that's a great question
very important question it's a big one
as well to try and to try and answer
okay I suppose the first thing to say
would be you mentioned manatees and an
oar home which people know about the
digital humanities I sports I in the
moment I'm working writing on the
digital manatees I'm trying to work out
my position in relation to the digital
humanities and the digit Maltese is not
one thing it's a whole set of fields
it's not even a field it's you know
doing lots of different things but one
of the things I'm curious about is the
tendency within a digital - to do very
much what you're talking about
so promote a very instrumental
performative kind of knowledge so you'll
get techniques and approaches from
computing science and say look we can
digitize the whole works of Chopin and
then we can read through it and look at
the data that we can get out of that and
I'm kind of curious about that because
in one hand I want to be open to people
doing new things and exploring new kinds
of knowledge on the other hand yeah
there's a part of me that's kind of okay
so we've as we were talking before we've
digitized that we've got this theater
out of the saw what is that it's just
for us to be more efficient more
performative more instrumental it seems
that the humanities in that particular
narrow aspect of the digital humanities
is taking on very much you know the walk
taking from the sciences what the
government telling us to do or
businesses telling us to do is like
search this do that so one of the things
I'm trying to work out with a lot of my
project is can we think of a digital
humanities that would be different that
would be what we would think in the
humanities is more interesting than that
without kind of the flip side to that as
going back to we all need to read more
books in really long books and disappear
for days on end and just really study
because otherwise our brains are all
going to get this kind of neurological
turn and we
concentrate on anything and we've all
got to be like Jonathan Franzen and Luco
yourselves aware for 10 years in a room
and fasten up our you know laptop ports
and saw things officer no-one can use
them in never be tempted by anything
again
can we you know not go to either extreme
can we work make this kind of stuff the
digital work for us in terms of the
humanities your question about you know
the humanities and we've kind of already
lost the battle and what can we do well
it just so happens that it's gonna give
an anecdote about Blue Peter which is a
children's program where they always
bring something on and say here's one I
made earlier but I am working because
one of the things we've been thinking
about we've you know we did a journal
and we did an archive and we're doing
kind of liquid books and a hoard
publisher so we're kind of thinking can
we scale this up a little bit so the
next project that we're thinking is we
want to do can we do a haul if you like
whooping access University can we make
all of this kind of available for free
and it gets the heart of some of the
things that you started off by talking
about in terms of you know you know my
generation and god I always end like I'm
old but my generation is probably maybe
the last generation that's working in
universities that has not any time to
give away now maybe this is the most
invaluable thing that we can do maybe
you know rather than any of the other
things we can be spending our time on
maybe just giving away some time so one
of things we're doing is setting up
institution where we're asking people or
we will be asking people then instead of
working and giving your labor for free
to academic journals or publishers who
are then gonna charge quite a lot of
money for people to get their products
don't do that give your time and lever
maybe an hour a week if enough people
did it it could be just as little as an
hour a week to support a whole open
access institution where we can continue
to teach the kind of humanities that
were interested in and think is
important even in situations as such as
you described where the situation is not
we're not thinking it's very
advantageous to the
attenuation of the humanities new
already in the UK just over the last few
weeks or even just the time I've been
here people are talking about the
privatization of the humanities how are
we going to continue to do the
humanities the government isn't prepared
to fund that anymore because it
precisely wants to go over to the
sciences and maths and medicine and it
wants us to do you know do that kind of
digital humanities I was talking about
that computational turn that data mining
version of it how can we continue to
find a space where we'll still ask the
kind of questions that most of us are
interested in doing can we do that we'll
have to do this I'm getting lower cost
because we're not going to have the
funds but in in the UK it's you know
people are talking about it in terms of
the class issue people won't be able
afford to go to universities anymore
they won't get that money so there'll be
a whole section of society that can't
have access to this kind of education
can we give them that as I said rather
than spending your time P reviewing for
journals that are then going to charge
I missed the slide though they're going
to charge you know quite a bit
I've got a bit of time I'll go through
back through the slides they're going to
charge hundred thousand dollars a year
to get those journals can we give our
time energy into making a different kind
of institution possible that's we're
gonna work on many kind of hard to
improvise this whole new University been
you mean quote that you put up I gather
you put it up as something of an epigram
since you didn't the the final slide
with the begging quote and it says here
he says that everything that matters is
to be found in the card box of the
researcher who wrote it I'm wondering if
that's something that you in fact
believe you know having put this up as
what I'm assuming is an epigram because
it seems to me one of the things that
open access does is allows the scholar
to maintain better control of his or her
intellectual property and the
intellectual property to me of a scholar
is the interpretation that he or she
uniquely applies to that gathering of
facts if it's just a gathering effect
computer algorithm could scan books scan
the web and gather those so I'm
wondering if you could address that
Thanks okay question this this is quote
from one-way street and I was kind of
putting that there to say look this is
all not just about the digital this
hasn't just happened with the emergence
of digital technology you know people
were already talking about the book and
these kind of fluid liquid terms back in
1928 the other quart I sometimes use
refers to Shakespeare and his first
polio which if you look at it it's you
know there is no one definitive answer
version of that it's got a whole lot of
different settings and typefaces and
spellings and it's you know it's not
fixed these books these texts aren't
fixed they're much more fluid and it is
kind of an interpretation yes one
version of open access would be that it
helps the scholar maintain their
resources it helps them in kind of
traditional ways of working why I'm
slightly pushing towards that is
precisely because of the issues that
were raised in the first question about
I just don't want this to be an
instrumental thing I don't think we
should use you know Presley is have you
seen that mode of instead of PowerPoint
it's the kind of where they put
everything on screen at once and it kind
of caught it always makes me carsick but
you know people swoop around and use
that or you know or delicious or all
those tools I think they're great and
they're kind of useful but I'm wary of
are we going to just get down to using
these things is in terms of instrumental
terms of making the humanities we can do
more faster quicker better for me it's
you know is that what we want the
humanities to be it's just that
performing better it's about asking
these kind of questions it's about
pushing what we understand the
humanities are what you know the kind of
questions that we should have been
asking anywhere but digital technology
pushes us towards and just thinking
about what the amount is going to be in
the digital era without falling into
that trap of you know we're going to
dare to mine masses and masses of texts
or going back in reactionary we all
need to get back to reading Middlemarch
and really concentrating on it with our
students which is great yeah like
Middlemarch as well people carry a
villian Georgia talk I wanted to just
push a little bit what seemed to be a
kind of liberal attention in the talk
between what I take to be the very
radical and egalitarian premises with
which you ended and the beginning
insistence on like course everything's
going to be paired with you and how do
we had we know I mean so that having
didn't previous question once say that
was its unique interpretation out there
I'm wondering whether that's still true
in in light of the kind of the kinds of
discussion you've outlined here do we
need do we still need if we if you're
not content with the can walk Cathleen
Fitzpatrick kind of crowdsourcing what
do we need in terms of response do we do
if the peer review thing is at least two
guys sitting in their room somewhere
quietly reading and deciding on some pub
of the arbitration they feel like
headache that day the guy doesn't cite
them in the footnotes there's a
reference to somebody they don't like
and the thing gets turned down that
strikes when you look at that percentage
difference between why humanities is so
rejection happy compared to the science
I wonder whether that's because all the
work in the humanities is so crappy
compared to the sciences of whether
we're just like you know very very kind
of petty-minded Ibaka's scientists are
much more normal minded and they don't
get involved in such things other ways
to do the research online I mean the
I've been trying to construct a climate
change project that's putting the work
online as I do it have you come have you
done any work in that area of like
weather just waiting till it's diamond
then shoving it up you know have you
thought about ways and ways the research
itself can be conducted in a
collaborative online format yes
okay so I'll start with the tension that
you talked about and I always build this
tension because I get invited to events
like this and I get invited to come and
speak about open access and I'm an
advocate and supporter of open access I
think it's really important and there's
a certain issue and this is where the
tension comes in a question of strategy
I want people to publish open access and
I think it's really important and I know
that people you know that in itself for
a lot of people is radical enough for me
that's a big jump and so a lot of people
in the open access movement think you
know that's a spa issue should go should
just push and say we've got publisher
open access and that's it
and the other side the other half that
you talked about which is intention this
it's gonna kind of frighten the horses a
little bit and people who already
nervous about open access I'm talking
about books and different kinds of peer
review no no see this is where it's
gonna lead us this is the kind of
trouble we're gonna get into let's not
go down that road at all and I don't
agree with that I think we should
publish open access there's nothing to
be scared about we can work it out most
of the open access movement most of open
access publications are peer reviewed in
very traditional ways
there isn't a question I'm raising these
questions because I am interested in it
I think you know I would say that I am
pushing this I'm not leaving open access
behind
I'm not moving beyond it I'm kind of
pushing its philosophy to its limits if
you like working through I mean these
are questions that were already in open
access you know people just don't ask
them because either they're not
interested in them or it's a question of
strategy are the different ways of peer
reviewing I mean it's all I'm talking
about this and I'm questioning the
author question notions a book it's not
to say that there just no limits and
it's all kind of a mess and it's chaos
and things of course we're going to make
different decisions we're not trying to
get rid of authorship what we're trying
to say is we need to these are things
that we've taken for granted we don't
really ask questions even you know I
work in cultural theory and we've been
through you know Barton
and Darood are and all of those people
but everyone still works kind of the
same we might think that we're
questioning the author but we still act
and this is the example I was using this
before we could act this very
traditional liberal humanist authors now
what I'm saying is that's not kind of
natural and fixed we can act differently
we couldn't think of different ways to
do and that's all we're trying to do
kind of loosen that up a little bit what
I'd like it's not to say have I got the
answer and I'm gonna convince it this is
what we should do I think we just need
to experiment and it's the same with
different kind of institutions we're
gonna have to experiment with what this
technology can do how we can use it
they're not going to be one answer
unless we start experimenting with it
we're never really going to find out
there's lots and lots and send you lots
of examples of different forms of peer
review I think by a MidCentral have this
this system what they call it's more
than a thousand but they have a thousand
peer reviewers and what they do is
nominate over a certain period what they
think is the most interesting articles
that were paired in that time and they
kind of pushed those forward and so
they're kind of trying a different
system a more collaborative collective
bigger system of doing that but there's
a lot of different examples of peer
review can work with with little books
we're making a lot more open not because
we're not going to make any judgments we
just want to say firstly to say look the
judgments that were taking you know
trying
sure that they're not just natural and
fixed that we can't change them and make
different kind of judgments and just try
to move to that other side we're going
to see what happens how can we judge
more collaboratively collectively
produced text what they're gonna look
like how would we still maintain notions
of quality and value I should stress
because very pleased with the return
which P has very kind of traditional
peer review system the way it's
organized might be kind of avant-garde
and radical but its system this is why
we've got you know I sure the slides
with all the kind of heavyweight hitters
it's got a very traditional serious
that's the point that's the strategy if
we don't have that
then people will still have that
attitude of publishing open access and
publishing books open access is it's
kind of not serious it's not proper we
can't afford to do it it's not
legitimate it's not quality control it
is I mean probably more than a lot of
print paper publishers I have the
question thank you for your talk very
interesting and noble experiment I my
question is there was a sentence you
said somewhere in there that eventually
you wanted to have the print sales cover
the costs of this and I'm from Columbia
University Press so I'm deal daily with
this difficult this dilemma we have
about market you know we'd love to
publish a certain book but we think we
would sell 200 copies and there's no way
we could cover our costs that we have to
say no and that's what this kind of
thing I think has the potential to to
change but right now it sounds as though
the University of Michigan is
essentially paying your a lot of your
whatever overhead you have you've
stripped it down people are doing the
work for free whatever office you have
would be covered by the university and
then the website and you wouldn't have
presumably marketing costs because
you're doing those you're sending out
emails or however you're you're doing it
on the website so you're stripping down
a lot of costs but eventually there are
costs I mean you're being paid a salary
not to do this work but to do something
else so what I guess what I'm getting at
is that universities have to recognize
that there are that they would have to
cover the costs of this kind of
publication because I don't think I mean
that was the one thing I was skeptical
about I don't think that your print
costs will subsidize especially if
you're not looking at market at all
because you won't get enough copies of
these obscure research monographs you
know probably you might sell 5 or 10 or
maybe even a hundred but even if you
sold a hundred at a relatively
reasonable price you wouldn't cover
those costs if usual broke them down
okay I was pleased to hear there was
only the one thing you were skeptical
about dollars that was quite nice yeah
all I'm just trying to find the slide
where we repress people
nearly there
okay yes people who say oh there's just
this one sentence in your text and then
University Press okay so yes the
question of costs and maintaining all
this yeah well I mean one of the people
that I founded which pay with which is
Paul Ashton he also runs repress and
they pretty much work on just that model
model of make the the the online version
free open access and then they're
getting money from the print on demand
version and what they're finding is it
does just about cover their costs they
publish people like Alan Barger who
there's you know a little what should we
say almost a cult around and they're
very enthusiastic people who like these
books and want to own their own personal
copy so they can have them on their
shelves so maybe it's to do with titles
that they're focusing on but they're
finally just about covers their cost but
it's a big question
big issue I'm not saying that I've got
the answer to how presses like Columbia
University Press are gonna solve this
problem suppose one thing that a lot of
people involved with open ax is gonna
say is well you're not gonna you know
you can't carry on the way it is because
that's not really working either I mean
I can could you lots of radical things
that I think should happen for example
you know in the UK the government's
always telling us that we that we're in
a knowledge Society and universities
help make the economy and their founding
businesses well you know if we're so
useful to businesses I'm not paying for
any of this because they don't
businesses don't pay us to do the
research they just take in that research
and building their businesses and
getting their money over well you know
why don't they start funding some of
universities and funding some of the
arts and humanities
given the money back and giving money to
people to publish research that's kind
of what I would say another argument is
that instead of every library this is an
argument made by David retain another
colleague of mine at which P instead of
what happens these libraries try and by
an individual copy of every book was
kind of published in the world that
they're interested in and they got ship
it to their buildings and then you've
got a store and gonna look after that
maybe you've got to switch that process
instead of universities and I'm trying
to get my institution to do this and
hatta meetings about it and they didn't
kick me out of the room what I'm saying
is instead of trying to suck all this
research in from everywhere if every
institution funded used that money to
just publish their own academics and
then you just pushed it out and made a
bill it made it available open access
then we'll all have access to this
research for free it would all be there
we'd all have it you wouldn't have the
problem of kind of storing it and
looking after it and shipping it that
would be another way of running that
this kind of system in this kind of
organization that would make it possible
the in departments and administrators
who are granting tenure would stop
insisting on a physical book because
that's I mean Biagio you'll sell enough
print-on-demand copies to make it work
and more but a revised dissertation and
a relatively obscure topic is not going
to do that and most people don't even
want the physical book they want to
search in it and then you put it away so
that's been the big stumbling block yeah
and that's partly why we adopted as a
strategy that we did with open
humanities press of going for more
established names because you thinking
okay to change that if we get a lot of
young younger scholars who are all very
familiar with Twitterer and all this
kind of thing then those kind of
committees and institutional bodies are
not going to change but if you get big
hitters who's saying hey this is
important this is what we should do and
you know they're coming to us because
they've been through
system and they're running out of
enthusiasm for in a lot of cases but you
know I don't want to position it as open
humanities press or open access versus
the likes of Columbia University Press I
mean you know I love books
I love print on paper books it's thanks
to people like Columbia that I get to
read them it's not you know it's not
this hostile either/or thing no no I
wasn't after trying to make that clear
so we're all straight and open access
now real problems we're all going to go
away and make all other things available
online yes that would be really great
yeah
any less questions anybody on Twitter
there was something
much smaller community so that actually
if you look at what the OEM Institute in
Chicago acceptance to it they putting
everything out as digital copy making
accessible through their website and it
is my impression I thought it necessary
in such a small fear by presentation
archaeology Lisa the people who are
using extremely effectively web and
digital publication rates are actually
reaching each other in the most
dispersed spots on the planet and I
wondered whether some of issues you were
describing are more related to the scale
that humanities in May
I thought of not having the push that
the scientists behind but still they are
much more powerful than small fields and
that's they right now squeezed another
there's there's lots of issues involved
a lot of people come to us like someone
is talking to someone about publishing a
classics series our classics kind of
strand via open humanities press and
they're coming to us because there are
kind of small field but there isn't a
market via the traditional publishers
for that field they can't get them to
take their books because traditional
publishers are having to at least make
ends meet if not make a profit and so
it's harder and harder for them to get
the kind of books that they want
published so they're coming to us as a
means of doing that so that's kind of
one reason why people are turning to
open access we were having a discussion
between us and the open humanities
people and there's a certain push with
certain parts of the world Pitt parts of
the world you know probably not the UK
or America but places who where they
feel a little bit on the margins so
there's a lot of open access things
happening in Australia for example and
one of the things people were saying is
well maybe because they feel quite far
away and it's hard to get their things
distributed and out there so this is a
really good way of doing that so there's
lots of reasons why particular fields
are going for it
the sciences are dominated it again for
various reasons because it's easy as I
was saying with journal articles there's
also a sense where they were already
exchanging preprints of their work
because if you're in science there's a
certain importance and spirits attached
to being the first to discover something
and you know in there's a sense of if
you discover a cure for cancer it's
important to kind of get it out there
quite quick rather than if I produce a
really interesting reading of dollars
you know if it takes 18 months for that
to come out I think it's a great loss
but you know most of the people would
prioritize one than the other so there's
a sense of where the sciences have
always been much quicker to get this
stuff
the much they want to share it there
already circulating it so something like
an open access repository like archive
just gonna formalize that or made that
possible okay I have the question to
what extent the scholars from developing
countries or rising powers are involved
in this because quite obvious cost is a
major issue here and it would seem that
they should be very important actors and
and collaborated in this open access
effort sure again there's not one
blanket answer to that so somebody like
in googy is interested in cookies uh
because she didn't know he was a
novelist writer he was up for the Nobel
Prize this year we were a bit
disappointed they didn't get that would
been great have someone in OHP with a
Nobel Prize and so he made a decision
sometime core it comes from Kenya and he
made a decision that he wouldn't write
in English anymore because that's the
colonial language and he was just going
to rewrite in Kikuyu is his language and
so we're publishing that series with him
but also he's going to write in those
language and publish but it's not going
to be just from that language translated
into English or translated into a French
it would be from that language into
another language that is outside the
center of those knowledge and publishing
networks but again and Carl started with
that court about open access it's not
kind of it's not this thing that
sometimes people know myself this
moralistic it's an inherent good and we
have to go and roll it out everywhere it
isn't a lot of people in South America
for example or nervous about open access
and cautious and sometimes when I go to
open access conferences why governments
are behind it is because they think you
know I got conferences in Europe and
they're saying we have to get our
knowledge out there we have to compete
with the Americans we have to make
ourselves north on the global market and
they think we have to have our knowledge
dominant and has to be out there
and sort of people in some places of the
world outside that see this is just
aware of the West the North making their
knowledge dominant and getting out there
so the certain people were cautious
which is why I was talking about having
different kind of networks and different
kind of publishing centers that makes it
possible you have a multi nodal network
so it's not just open access mix north
america or europe or the UK and then
knowledge out there that there are other
parts of the world that can could start
publishing their research in in
globalizing that if you like
you